okay wow people love the internet retro
rack and two are here just a dad who
loves games and the stories they tell
and yes this is the end of an era we
have some important things to talk about
today exciting things and I want to be
very clear with everybody here Hogwarts
Legacy has changed my life it's changed
the course of this channel the community
here that we have found through Hogwarts
Legacy it really truly has changed my
life now I've been hearing you guys I've
seen all those requests for you wanting
me to do more types of content and cover
more things but for the past three years
I mean virtually the entirety of this
Channel's lifespan I have also had a
full-time job you guys know just a dad
who loves games and the stories they
tell I'm also a dad two kids wife and
the full-time job with all of this other
stuff as the YouTube has grown and grown
and grown it hasn't been easy at all and
so I heard all those questions and a lot
of times I wanted to do a lot of those
things but it was just impossible for me
to add anything more to my plate really
truly impossible given how much we're
already trying to do here and so that's
why I quit
still sounds so crazy to say man and no
uh I didn't quit YouTube I quit my
full-time job I am no longer employed
anywhere except here by you sort of and
I'll be totally honest with you guys
it's scary it's it's terrifying and at
the same time it's one of the most
exciting things that I've ever done with
my life and I've always been in terms of
taking risks I've always been one
play it by the rules you know just do
exactly what you're supposed to do in
school go to college get the degree get
a decent job and like my dad's
generation explaining this to him it's
just such a crazy wild concept to even
think about leaving a stable job for
something that is a bit more of a risk
but it is just
it excites me like like nothing else you
know I love doing this I love streaming
live with you guys I love interacting
with you all as a community in the live
streams on Discord hearing your feedback
on videos it's amazing and thanks to
your help thanks to your support you all
put me in the position to be able to do
this and I don't want to anyone to be
worried about my family to think I'm
putting my family in Jeopardy or
anything like that my wife also has a
very stable job so don't feel like you
need to give me sympathy or anything
trust me I I know what kind of risk I'm
taking I know the position we're in
financially and where we're at as far as
the YouTube channel goes so it's a
calculated risk all right so back to the
title of the video though what happens
now what happens next obviously Hogwarts
Legacy is out we're still putting out
videos on that game it's doing very well
our videos are doing well hopefully
they'll continue to do well I never just
wanted this to be only a Hogwarts like Z
Channel that's not what is was about
didn't even want it to just be a
Wizarding World Channel I think you guys
know if you've followed me long enough
you know I'm not going to make a
decision like this lightly without a
plan right so I really have put together
kind of a five-step plan and the thing
about YouTube is you always have to be
nimble you have to be willing to adjust
so if we try some of these things and
they don't work we may have to Pivot and
you may see that so here's the plan
going forward what you guys can expect
from the channel now that we are full
time here as a content creator number
one Hogwarts Legacy yes it's true the
channel is going to have to grow it's
gonna have to change it's gonna have to
evolve we're gonna have to do more
things we're gonna have to get outside
of just being a Hogwarts like creator
however I'm not going to forget where I
came from guys while Hogwarts Legacy
isn't one of those multiplayer games
that you can just build an entire
Channel off of we are absolutely going
to cover that game probably like no
other game I mean we're going to make
sure that we stay on top of all the
Hogwarts Legacy stuff so don't worry if
you found me because of Hogwarts Legacy
expect more Hogwarts so I can see that
is not going to change we're going to
keep covering everything with that game
and to be honest with you guys and this
is no inside information whatsoever but
I believe I've said this a number of
times now and I'm not saying this just
because we have a channel covering this
but I really do feel like this is kind
of the launch of a new era of The
Wizarding World I mean you think about
sort of the history of Harry Potter you
had the books right like that was one
phase and then kind of as the books
ended
the movie started before the books were
finished but still it was like you you
had that phase where the books were
still coming out then we shifted then we
were in that movie phase right so I
really think and again this is my guess
here but I think they've been looking
for like what is that next big thing for
the Wizarding World so I think we could
be seeing the launch of a whole new wave
of Wizarding World games now we have no
idea if any of these are in development
right now of course there's Harry Potter
magic awakened which may one day come
out here in the U.S Hogwarts Legacy I
think 100 will get DLC despite what's
being said right now you know I think
it's coming sequel I think will
inevitably come as well but Avalanche as
a studio they can only do so much right
so what else I think the incredible
success of Hogwarts Legacy has shown
people that hey this property is still
huge there's still a lot of people
behind it there's still a lot of people
that love this world what else can we do
so all of your cries for quidditch and
multiplayer MMO a game with the founders
a game where you play as an or after
school a game where they remake the old
games right I mean I think all of those
are probably on the table for WB right
now again I'm just speculating here so
keep those ideas coming whether in
comments below whether you're tweeting
at people WB on Twitter because if I
could say this about WB and Avalanche
from the limited amount of time that
I've worked with him is that they listen
and they hear you guys they may not
always be able to do exactly what people
want every single time right but trust
me they are listening and they are
watching so I think it will be really
interesting to see what happens from
here with the Wizarding World as an IP
and also with Hogwarts Legacy regardless
of where our Channel goes we will be
covering those things rest assured of
that okay number two the Tuesday live
streams and I know it's kind of ironic
that I'm posting this the week that we
missed a Tuesday live stream however
that
show and doing that live stream which we
called retro Rec inter live has been
such a fun part of my week man the vibe
that we got just the hanging out and I
have to give credit to my buddy James
expect to go seeing his live stream and
how he interact with his community I've
told him this so many times like oh my
gosh dude like seeing that seeing the
level of interaction and the level of
passion and dedication that he had from
you guys the audience and I know we
share a lot of you guys watching now are
also fans of James so Tuesday live
streams not going anywhere it will have
to grow and evolve I think eventually
that will probably become more of a
general kind of gaming news show where
we hang out and you guys already know I
mean even if we have a list of topics
chat's gonna take us at some totally
different area so we'll cover things
like Hogwarts Legacy on there cover
General Wizarding World News and also
General gaming news as well so I may try
to come in each week with a list of I
don't know five or so topics and we'll
kind of break them down on the Tuesday
Night Live stream I don't really want
that one to be a gameplay stream more on
that in a second I know we've kind of
been doing some gameplay streams with
that right now because of the Hogwarts
Legacy launch but over time I see that
as more of an interactive new show
almost like a podcast that's interactive
where we're talking live with you guys
so rest assured that will continue to
live here on YouTube Tuesday evenings 8
P.M eastern time all right but number
three that takes me to gameplay streams
one of the things that I have missed so
much is not being able to do gameplay
streams so when we made the decision to
switch from twitch to YouTube and focus
more on creating content creating value
for people all the while working my
full-time job I had to make a sacrifice
so I had to cut out the live streams
that we used to do those of you who have
been following us closely know we've
been picking the live streams back up
because you guys didn't know I'd
actually already quit my job live
streams gameplay live streams one of my
favorite things to do right now I am
leaning toward the home for those being
on Twitch that's kind of where we're at
right now and of course we're going
through Hogwarts Legacy we're going to
play the heck out of that game 100 and
all that fun stuff but then I want to
pick back up I want to do our order of
Phoenix I want to finish that let's play
I want to do Half Blood Prince I want to
do all the Potter games and then I want
to get to my backlog guys I hesitate I'm
afraid to admit this but guys I have not
beaten Red Dead 2 I haven't beaten
Persona 5 I haven't beaten Spider-Man
Miles Morales so many games that I trust
me I know I would love them I know I
would love them I know how good they are
I already know that trust me but I just
haven't been able to do it because I've
been making content for you guys so the
gameplay live streams right now again
this is all kind of like tentative plans
but I want to just let you guys know
where I'm at I'm thinking Tuesdays
Wednesdays Thursdays some point during
the day so I'm on Eastern time I've been
experimenting we did some kind of early
like starting around 9 10 a.m eastern
time we've been experimenting with
starting a little bit later like 1 2 p.m
in the afternoon eastern time so we're
just gonna keep feeling all that out and
seeing exactly what time works best when
we have the most people showing up when
you guys can be there and participate
all right number four videos covering
other games I enjoy doing new style
content I do I enjoy making News videos
however there's a big problem with those
on YouTube is that they have a very
short lifespan and what I mean by that
is they're only relevant for a very
short amount of time depending on what
it is right and how long you have when
we first started covering Hogwarts
Legacy trust me I didn't know that it
was going to be delayed and that we were
gonna have to keep making News videos
for that whole extra year so we didn't
know that at the time I still would have
probably done it anyway but I don't want
to get into that cycle of only being a
news channel because then you're on this
never-ending kind of hamster wheel of
just trying to churn out the content
daily daily daily date some people do it
they do a great job at it that's not
what I want us to do I will still cover
gaming news there may be a video or two
that pops up for me that covers some
things I think we'll strategy more like
compilations like package things
together that's also where the Tuesday
live stream comes in on YouTube that's
where we can talk about those types of
things however I do want to make videos
that cover other games it's just going
to be more what they call Evergreen
content content that hopefully is not
Irrelevant in a week after the news
break so it may be you know me going
back and playing Red Dead and then doing
kind of a retrospective video letting
you guys know what I think about it
playing it all these years later not
really a review per se but just more of
a deep dive into what I feel about the
game when we first start posting videos
like that they're probably not going to
do well I mean you guys can see when
we've done we've done like some God war
videos they don't do well I'm going to
commit to it though and it's going to
take a lot of time if you actually click
on one of our videos and you're like oh
I'm gonna help retro out I don't really
care about this but I'm gonna I'm gonna
click on it and watch it for five
seconds and then dip that actually is a
mostly negative signal to YouTube
because it tells them that oh wow it
could be a clickbaity thumbnail so what
it's telling them like oh geez they
clicked it but then five seconds they
were gone they didn't like that video at
all and then YouTube's not going to
promote it so if you see something that
you enjoy that you're genuinely
interested in for me click on it and
just try to watch it all the way through
that is going to be the biggest thing
and people people always want to talk
about likes shares and subscribes yeah
all those things help but watch time is
king So if you're enjoying the video
stick around till the end all right
number five story based videos this may
be the one that I'm most excited about
it's kind of the most risky and I don't
want to give away too much on it just
yet but I mean we
call our Channel I mean the tagline just
the dad who loves games and the stories
they tell we're gonna make story based
videos around like characters in video
games that we have right now so I'm
looking at doing some around some of the
Hogwarts Legacy character so I feel like
that would be kind of a good transition
to help people sort of learn this new
format while also holding over the old
audience like check this out guys you
know we've got some Hogwarts Legacy
stuff and then Branch out covering even
more video game characters and even more
video game stories so the actual stories
the the lore The Narrative of the video
game
and really doing kind of deep Dives on
these so I see this as a little
different from point number four because
this one is specifically focused on
story so again I'm not giving away too
much on this one yet there's still a lot
of things that I'm working out and
forming but these videos they're going
to be you know spread out more they're
not going to be like churned out weekly
for sure you know like maybe we could
work up to to one a month because I
really want these to be well researched
Deep dive well thought out videos uh
that hopefully you guys will enjoy all
right so to wrap all this up how can you
guys help right how can you help with
this new
era right this new era of retro Recon
tour what can you guys do
because I know how our community is I
know how ridiculously generous you are
that that's
it feels so weird trust me if I I it's
almost cringy right to even bring up
like well donations and subs and
remember
but I know you guys like I know that's
the question a lot of people are gonna
be asking let me just say
we even have people who say like dude I
feel bad all these people are donating I
wish I wish I could do
look you do not have you never have to
pay a dime or a cent to support this
channel if you've watched this far I
don't even know how long this video is
going to be it's probably going to be a
longer one but if you've watched this
far you are a huge part of this and a
huge reason for why this is even
possible to happen so ways that you guys
can support without literally spending
anything other than your time which is
incredibly valuable in and of itself
liking videos like we mentioned watching
them all the way through commenting
interacting with the community if you
like something you know sharing it with
someone else those are all so huge being
there for live streams chatting during
the live streams
that helps so much more than you know
really unless your con creators if
you're a Creator out there you know how
important those things are because I
mean the community is everything the
audience you guys watching this that is
the reason any of this is even possible
now that being said I do have people who
ask well which one helps you the most in
terms of twitch or YouTube bits
memberships donations do I donate here
dude so I don't want to get into all
that here in the video what I will do is
I'll put up a post on Discord kind of
explaining this even further and for
those of you who are curious and who
want to help out in that way we'll put
something in the video description as
well but we do have things like
affiliate links guys so if you shop on
Amazon you know we got Amazon affiliate
links epic Creator code raconteur things
like that they all help out as well and
then of course everything that we're
doing here on YouTube with Channel
memberships subscriptions over on Twitch
as well those types of things but if you
really want to know more of the details
I'll explain in the description and over
on Discord oh yeah official merch store
too where you can buy hats like this one
so to wrap up this video have I said
that multiple times that's like a big
YouTube No-No so if you if you've made
it this far congrats I'm I'm breaking a
lot of YouTube rules with this video
it's this one's not going to be as
highly edited as normal but I don't feel
like it should be right I mean this
should be real I should be speaking to
you guys you know I had a little outline
here in front of me of topics that I
wanted to hit but the overall message of
this is just thank you
thank you and this is like I said with
the thumbnail and the title I mean this
is the beginning of a new era but this
is this is really just the beginning man
it really is and to
um
I mean just thinking about my kids man
just thinking about my kids and you know
James talked a little bit about this too
of like
something that my kids will be able to
look back on one day when I'm no longer
here they'll be able to watch this video
and be like he took a chance man look
look at the passion hopefully you guys
can see the passion and dedication for
things like this and that you know the
whole cliche of like dreams coming true
and going after your dreams trust me
guys I know that it doesn't work for
everyone I know how many Failed YouTube
channels there are I may look back on
this video in a year and be applying for
jobs and being like wow I made a fool of
myself but
no I'm posting this I'm putting this out
there I want you guys to see it and I
want you guys to know
speaking from right here man speaking
from right here so uh again thank you
all so much for everything that you've
done just the beginning
uh I want to hit how about let's let's
try and hit 100K for the end of this
year 100K subscribers man I want that
plaque dude I know it's a vanity metric
I know it's not truly the thing that
matters but if you guys aren't subbed to
the channel yet hit that sell button
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new videos but yeah dude I I really I
really want the 100K if you guys don't
know about this when you hit 100K Subs
on YouTube they send you this this
plaque or I guess it's more like a frame
I don't know I don't know but it but it
looks awesome and then if you hit a
million
send you another one as always guys
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon